Bernie Sanders has been criticized for
his lack of foreign policy experience
but is that true after all he has spent
25 years in Congress voting on foreign
policy issues by comparison both
presidents Obama and Reagan have less
experience when they became president so
here's what you need to know about
Bernie's foreign policy first off
Sanders is no pacifist he voted for the
war in Afghanistan and for the NATO
intervention in the Balkans back in the
90s but Sanders does err on the side of
restraint and is critical of what he
calls the Pentagon's bloated budget he
was one of a mere three senators who
voted against the defense budget
increase in 2015 and unlike Clinton he
opposed the invasion of Iraq in 2003
fifth I am concerned about the problems
with so-called unintended consequences
who will govern Iraq when Saddam Hussein
is removed and what role with the US
play in an ensuing Civil War that could
develop in that country and civil war is
pretty much what happened one that
destabilized the entire region and
helped give the world Isis Sanders
believes the u.s. is fight against Isis
should be limited to airstrikes he also
wants Muslim nations like Saudi Arabia
and Iran to leave that fight on the
ground but it's ideas like that that
makes some people question Sanders
ability to find foreign policy solutions
Saudi Arabia and Iran are major arrivals
it seems optimistic to expect them to
suddenly work together especially when
they're fighting proxy wars all over the
region one of those places is in Syria
Sanders again sets himself apart from
Clinton on the now five-year civil war
whereas Clinton believes in a bold
no-fly zone Sanders cautions against it
he thinks Assads removal should not come
at any cost in Libya Clinton push for
the nato-led invasion that toppled
Moammar Gadhafi and Sanders wasn't
strongly opposed though he now says that
regime change usually ends up making the
situation worse Qaddafi was a brutal
dictator there's no question but one of
the differences between the secretary
and I is I'm not quite so aggressive
with regard to regime change and on
Israel Palestine Bernie Sanders who is
Jewish has gone further in criticizing
the Israeli government than any other
candidate while he did support
Israel's 2014 war on gaza he now
criticizes it and wants the blockade
lifted as for Iran sander supports the
nuclear agreement and says that while
the priority should be to make sure
Tehran doesn't get nuclear weapons war
should be the last resort then there's
Latin America where Sanders has one of
the most progressive records in Congress
he's called out the US is long history
of intervention in the region the United
States was wrong to try to invade Cuba
that the United States was wrong trying
to eat support people to overthrow the
Nicaraguan government that the United
States was wrong trying to overthrow in
1954 the government democratically
elected government of Guatemala it's a
critique he's held for years and has
even blamed us business interests for
being the motive behind this
intervention time and time again these
interventions in Latin and Central
America have been at the for the benefit
of large corporations whether it's the
United Fruit Company in Guatemala or the
tinny companies or the copper companies
in Chile Sanders defining positions on
Latin America today include lifting the
economic embargo on Cuba and allowing
debts trapped Puerto Rico to file for
bankruptcy overall Sanders is more
reluctant than most politicians to push
for war saying that the focus should be
on fixing America we are going to
rebuild in a cities in this country
rather than waste trillions on wars we
never ever should have gotten into so is
that the kind of foreign policy thinking
we need more of